okay hi everyone we are back for another
live stream in a pretty intense day of
live streams
this one is about pde modeling for
version 13 of orphan language
so i was warned that
what we're discussing here is
complicated
so
let's uh should i start by opening the
guide page
uh you could do that yeah
okay so by for context these are
wrappers for creating
essentially setting up models
for pdes
and
we we are steadily adding new domains
for that
and we have fluid mechanics yet
no
uh as we've come to a new domain now
which is
um solid mechanics solid mechanics and
it's not in there sorry about that
okay all right so where should i start
start with a solid mechanics pd
component
and i
oh my gosh it's the famous spoon
so
i think oliver is going to have to take
the lead on a lot of this but just a
very very brief outline is that
what we solve for in the equations is
for displacement
which means how much the material has
moved at a particular point
so i thought that these were stressful
from the plate displacement you can get
the strain so there is a function that
does that and from the strain you can
get the stress
okay
we're the young's modulus or something
like that yes
okay so let me understand what's
happening so in in the object
there
is so
these are what are these equations
called i forgotten what they're called
the the
some french person what where the help
what is this what are the standard solid
mechanics equations called
oliver
well it's linear elastic
um constitutive equations you mean
kinematic equations
um i mean
maybe you mean lame equations
yes that's one yeah that's a special
case yeah
okay so i'm trying to understand here so
so so there's a simple case which is
what oliver just hinted at which is
linear elastic material that's a
material that sort of bounces back
um once you've
removed the force
and
right so this is a standard thing with
the young's modulus and personal ratio
that's sort of standard simple for solid
mechanics right yep
okay
um
so in 3d
i mean
you could formulate in any number of
dimensions but we mostly live in three
dimensions so far as well
yeah so 2d and 3d so the the main thing
is this entire
thing lives in 3d
and there are simplifications that you
can have in 2d but they're
simplifications so
yeah
okay but i mean
the structure of the lemay equations
does not depend on dimensionality does
it correct yeah
that's correct
but if you go up you can see that the
equations are different depending on if
you think that you have isotropic
material of course
you know anisotropic or right but i mean
the first approximation we're dealing
with isotropic linear materials that
will be the simplest elastic elastic is
an important point yes okay yeah yeah
but linear elasticity so it means that
the stress strain relation is linear
correct right
okay
so
boy okay
all right so there's a divergence here
of
what is this thing here this is the
stress tensor
okay
and how did i give that stress tensor
here it's just saying material like this
no no no you
you can give it but that's really not
what you want to do so basically you
specify the material and the stress
tensor is assembled from that material
so that's got a young's modulus from a
personal ratio in other words it's a
diagonal stretch it extracts what it
needs from the material and does what
it's supposed to do if you want to you
can give young's modulus and point
source ratio okay that's what you're
doing here and it does the same thing
yeah
all right it's great
okay
that's simple there's no need for you to
know this
if you want to do it if you have like a
from a textbook some specific material
data you want to enter them you can do
that but you don't have to do that and
certainly not the the initial way to do
it
what is this thing why isn't a 3x3
tensor what is this
yeah so basically this the tensor is
actually a four tensor but because no
one wants to deal with four tensors
there's a specific notation that's used
it's called voice notation and that
reduces its four tensor because of
symmetries and whatnot
to this six by six uh matrix oh yuck you
know this business about packing data
you know because people haven't wanted
to deal with nested lists
they pack data in these weird ways i
mean it's the same thing as done
in um electromagnetism right for f you
know
i mean
people uh
people take apart these anti-symmetric
tensors and repack them in different
ways it's super confusing yeah but i
mean why aren't we using because we can
deal with necessarily because virtually
every textbook you're going to find is
going to be in this or a similar
notation and you'll find that we should
have converters in and out of it you
want to be able to take the material
data you get from suppliers and enter
them in this specific way
so but we should have a converter to and
from this but internally we should work
with i mean internally we're doing this
we're exposing this so the thing that
you see below there this is this for
tensor
that's what it does
okay no one in no one is used to this to
being able to to i mean we had this the
possibility for customers to enter this
four tensor with the diffusion operator
uh for for at least one version
the this isn't
this is
is this the
three this is a three by three and there
is um
uh what three three of them
in for each dimension so it's a three by
three by three yeah exactly and that's
the four tensor yeah beautiful yeah
and and you you can enter them if you
want to enter it this way but
why don't we have a wrapper that's
called a voice something or other
i have this internally this conversion
um i can expose something like this but
um i mean this is it's it's all quite
complicated and i didn't want to expose
too much of this internal framework
right away
but to me the thing that would make the
most sense is if that thing is called
a
you know
whatever it's called avoid
voice notation
why don't you just have a thing that
says
you know white tensor or whatever it is
of this thing
and that essentially evaluates maybe
doesn't actually evaluate but it is
treated as
the corresponding three by three by
three object yeah so if you scroll down
a little further down there is a
linear
anisotropic elastic material model
and that is entered in that specific way
so even a little bit further this is the
linear orthotropic one and the next one
is the linear
um
an isotropic one and the matrix we refer
to is called the compliance matrix or
elasticity matrix
you'll enter this entire thing okay fine
but but i mean my point is
what i'm suggesting is that you have a
rapper that says you know
well i'm trying to understand which way
around this goes so basically you you
want like voice notation to for tensor
yes but i don't know exactly i mean what
i'm suggesting is
that
it'd be possible to go both ways like if
you get a four chance out you should be
able to unpack it into this thing and i
have these functions internally i need
to do this so
okay well i wonder whether there's
analogous whether there are other cases
i mean roger
even in something like you know lr lud
composition or something we've we've
again got
well there we break it up into three
objects but aren't there cases in in
sort of linear algebra
law where you do this kind of packing
true or not true
yeah it is true so so
okay two things that's worth mentioning
one is a very explicit form that we use
for positive semi-definite matrices
symmetric positive semi-definite
matrices
there is a convention to sort of
represent them because their dimension n
times n plus one over two as opposed to
dimension n squared
um that linear space so we use that
packing for instance in all the
optimization things
now there's also structured matrices
where you have many fewer
sort of elements like a vandoman matrix
or something like that literally is
specified by a vector
right you know and so we have a project
that's coming up
uh in a little bit called structured
arrays or structured matrices
that will
allow you to
enter them and take advantage of it so
right now we have a few things
that just
the ones that we have now
just auto convert it into dense matrix
and which destroys all the structure
and destroys all the computational
complexity
maybe maybe we don't want to do that
right maybe we want a function called a
ray convert
that does things
for these different forms of packing
like people have totally asked symmetric
ten you know um
like f mu nu and electromagnetism um
maybe totally yeah right so then
and then we have a string argument and
then we can just convert
there's also and this is
you know a different project we were
working on in the background here which
is that
there are many
sort of
ways that higher
tensors get
converted into matrices
so there are many ways of flattening
basically well i mean a ray flattened
does one of them but but that's not the
only but when you have more structure in
the array right other things you can do
the question is what you want to
preserve in structure there when you do
that
and so that's like that's
that that is its own language i don't
think it could be kind of an array com
well maybe there are no maybe there's a
few discrete ones that one could do that
way but i think there's like a whole
language that one needs for that for
which
for the for the different kinds of
flattenings
you know you can flatten to any level so
to speak no i know the way to vector you
know right right right we've got a lot
of technology for platinum i mean we've
done quite a lot on the calculus of
flattening
yes but but this is conventions
but
well one thing is
very organized and essentially geometric
flattening so to speak
which we think we're doing with with
core functions like array flatten
okay
okay then there is convention flattening
like voice notation or whatever right
and that would fit array converts you
know
the scenario do you think and that thing
that i brought up this the positive
symmetric minister
that thing
to vector that would also fit that
particularly
that's it that's uh yeah i mean for me
it would have been useful if i had had
something like that so
fine i think we should do this i mean i
guess just to you know this is a
convention you know this is just gonna
have a boatload of random conventions in
here
for different fields and so on
um
seems useful to me
okay so so here you're saying compliance
matrix so that will be a a string that
will be a key in an association and an
array convert you'll be able to say take
this three by three by three tensor and
you know array convert to a compliance
matrix
or yeah i don't know how you do the
other way around i guess we do the same
thing that we do in
translation we would say compliance
matrix
if it's three by three by three why do
you call it the fourth answer
no it's three times
four times three three by three by three
by three
by three yeah
oh yeah right yeah it's got another one
okay
all right so so let's keep going here
um
i think i understand what this is doing
so so
uh should we go on to the next thing
solid mechanics stress and strain
yeah i'm sure so those are
so once you've got the displacement um
you'd like to be able to compute the
strain and the stress
why isn't i thought strain was delta x
oh displacement is delta x strain is
delta x over x
is that correct
yes
where x is x the original length yeah
yes yeah
so the only difference the displacement
field is just delta
x whatever you know for a given fiducial
point
it is the motion it is the difference of
the
you know
it's where that particular point is
moved to yes it's different correct
correct
okay
and this meshes where
this function that we have is
displacement plot and displacement plant
okay so this is another example where
you need a rake but because this is all
producing weird packet packed objects
okay so wait a minute what is this doing
now
go ahead as usual you give variables and
parameters so no parameters are needed
here and the variables are uh u v and w
in the x y and z direction
and then there's a
symbolic displacement
an arbitrary displacement i've chosen
and it converts this into the strain
and that's the the resulting uh the
resulting strain matrix
of this of this conversion i am very
confused okay hold on so this here
i don't understand why why is this
this is two things so that's
what are you vw are they the delta
those are the variables in the x y and z
direction so if we think about what
displacements or not
no they're the variables like like like
in the previous like the
um solid mechanics pd components has
variables and parameters
these are exactly the same variables and
parameters like you've given
for the solid mechanics pde component
exactly the same thing
okay the displacement is the last
argument that's the displacement
okay
okay
i mean if you look open the stationary
analysis example maybe that that's one
that has a complete workflow
so this is supposed to be the
displacement field uvw correct yeah
those are the displacement variables
correct
and these are the independent variables
correct
all right okay and the material is
silver you've got the spoon
and you have this
the pd component for the spoon and then
there is a boundary load at one end so
there's a force acting on the tip of the
spoon
and the back end of the spoon is held
fixed
i think we're going to have to find that
actual tea place well the original spoon
was was exposed
and scanned the original scene after all
this effort
i'm not sure we're going to find that
but uh well
somewhere in munich
but you know what steven i'm sure it
wasn't silver you know
yes i'm sure it wasn't i i'm not sure
um
the uh
okay
in any case um
all right so this is a force
and he's sold in the negative z
direction solid boundary load value
that's okay that's the i know analog
of one of these acoustic absorbing
values
correct yes
okay
that's pretty cool
so and now you see in the next argument
you see the solid mechanic strain vars
parse and the displacement and returns
the strain in the entire object
solid fixed condition
the heck is that so that means
at the at this position the solid is
completely fixated it's like like
fixated like a dirichlet boundary
condition of a sort yes so everything
that ends in condition is is equivalent
to a dirichlet condition and everything
that's ends that ends in a value is a is
a neumann value
or it corresponds or results in a
neumann value
okay
so this is
at this position
constrain
variables
yes
constrain the displacement
right i'm sorry where is okay so vars is
that whole thing
i'm a little confused by
the fact that in nd solve
these are the dependent variables and
these are the independent variables and
now they're being packaged into a single
thing
that is just called vars right
yeah but remember that they're both
variables right dependent and
independent variables they're both yeah
i understand that i mean
there was a streamlining we added after
a while when we did so much of this
modeling i mean if you if you remember
like the acoustics or the heat transfer
we had the same thing just the
difference now is that we have three um
dependent variables so this this returns
a set of three dependent variables or
equations while the previous ones only
returned one equation
so this is this this solid mechanics
generates systems of equations
but here where you say vars oh yeah you
do have the same thing you have you have
u of x and
yeah
and that was done with with uh with the
idea so that we can extend it to systems
of equations and we've done that now
why is this a single u of x is that just
a convention that you can yes that's a
convenience you can wrap it in another
braces but you don't have to okay
well this looks pretty cool i mean
i actually think there's not so much to
review here for me i mean unless unless
you what
okay so we
can ask something so yeah
um i've done the linear cases now the
non-linear cases are really really
complicated and i want to be very honest
here i'm not a hundred percent sure that
the design that i've made is gonna is
gonna fit all the cases
and for this reason and and i haven't i
have done a few non-linear cases but i
haven't done all that i want to do but
for this reason i would like to request
that these these um ref pages are marked
as experimental
but let me just understand
you have a solid okay
and
there is stress and there's strain yeah
and the relation between those can be
incredibly complicated yes
okay this is partly what happens when
you go non-linear yeah i realized that i
realized that and i mean and there's
hysteresis and all kinds of weirds yes
it's not only
not only
for example right and then some you get
to plastic deformation yeah where things
stay
stay deformed right right but i mean in
but i'm trying to understand in terms of
the the pdes
the relationship between stress and
strain i see there's
there's things like this time-dependent
relationship or path-dependent
relationship yeah and you don't think
you've modeled that correctly i'm sure
you haven't that's really complicated i
don't even know how pdes do that
you can do it so for example you you
have to kind of add events so if you
if a part of the object is beyond a
certain point for example the yield
point of a material then it's going to
start to behave differently the the pde
but i don't understand okay let's
imagine you have a shape memory alloy
yeah okay
and you twist it into the shape of a
duck or something yeah right
how on earth is that represented in this
so so in other words
you've got
how does that wait a minute how on earth
do you so
so you say
there is defamation that gets to that
point
yeah
and that's going to be most likely going
to be a non-linear deformation because
the the amount of deformation is very
large it's a geometric non-linear
problem
okay so fine so but now i don't
understand how you had to you could
mention that too oliver there's like two
classes of non-linearities what did you
call the other one the smaller so okay
so there's so if you have so
if you go to the pd modeling page above
there's in the in the um no sorry in the
solid mechanics pd components i'm sorry
yeah that one
so you you have
something that's called the kinematic
equation that relates the strain to the
displacement if that relation is
non-linear we speak of geometric
non-linearity
if the relation between
what is strain i thought strain was
always defined as delta x over x
is that not correct
yes it's correct
but
the way it's done is basically it's
it's computed as a gradient of the
deformation so there's different
measures for strain uh yeah for strain
and the one we use is is computed by the
diff by a by computing the gradient of
the deformation
okay loosely speaking yeah but wait
deformation is the same as displacement
yes
okay yeah
okay
um correct so if if that relation is
non-linear then you have a geometric
non-linearity now
which relation i'm sorry which relation
the relation between delta x the delta x
field and the delta x over x field
yeah so
the strain is a function of the
displacement
yes and it that doesn't necessarily have
to be a linear relation
okay so a more complicated model than
delta delta delta x over x
there's more complicated models than
that
and that's well fine so what you're
saying is if i have a crystal for
example and i'm asking you know where i
just have a bunch of atoms arranged and
i'm asking
characterize the configuration of the
crystal
you're saying one way i can do that is
just to say the delta over x over x
field everywhere but the crystal might
have some more complicated arrangement
of where its atoms actually are
no
no
well um
think about
um
well what's what's an example think
about a foam if you have a foam material
so if you if you press the foam together
um
it's not you you
there's only a small portion of the of
of the pressing together that's actually
that's linear with the stress and the
strain how how did no no because that's
a different thing that's the
constitutive relationship yeah that
that's the material
i thought that the definition of strain
was delta x over x that's what's
confusing me but that was the definition
of strain you could have some other
property of a material but that was the
definition yeah
so
small displacements and small rotations
you say here yeah
that that's the actual strain measure
that we use
um
right and we should rap in just a moment
here because i'm supposed to another
quite different live stream um
so
so part of what we would like to you
know which we haven't completed and we
want to say in experimental is these two
stages of non-linearity
um
that they mentioned the last one being
geometric ones for big big
non-linearities okay i got a couple of
general generalized comments then we
should
i mean
obviously as you go to more and more
non-linear elasticity
in the end
i mean it could be arbitrary i mean you
know the thing could yeah
yeah some yes
you know duck has muscles in it and it's
got you know it's all kinds of
creativity yeah absolutely you're right
yeah it gets very complicated you know
biological material for instance is
is
you know examples of that right
so i mean composite materials is
examples of that so so i mean what your
issue is
so make this experimental
you know perhaps what will need to
happen i think we can go a little
farther but i think that we have to stop
kind of somewhere i would stop and i
would stop and i would see how this
works and maybe at some time in the
future there'll be a non-linear solid
mechanics pde component
that has even more general types of
things because i think that the design
for the full nonlinearity of the duck
with its actin filament muscles and god
knows what else right
is is just you know at that point it's
sort of a merging with some complicated
pde generalization of system model or
something yeah but i think the part of
what we want to get to at least is the
plastic or some form of plastic
definitely so
basically bulk materials yeah yeah okay
so the question is what
are the possible forms of bulk materials
i have to say i would do fluid mechanics
before you do really weird normal
elasticity
because fluid mechanics i mean one
feature of liquids is at some level
they're all the same they've just got
viscosity and they've got to behave a
little weirdly when they move at high
speeds indeed indeed i mean that you
know what by the time you're not you
know non-zero mach number so to speak
and by the time you've got i mean that
all kinds of weird stuff happens right
so some of that we're we're we're um
but for the equations it's not ramping
up both both fluid and electromagnetics
you know this is good we're hiring for
and
what about what about general activity
that's not on our road that's probably
i'm probably not the right person to do
that but i'm i'm willing to especially
we do have you know one feature is we do
have people who actually really know
that field pretty well
so can we engineer black holes then and
we can ship them maybe
no but people the whole point is the
whole point is people use that
technology
no no i i'm anyway
and it would be nice to be able to
connect
i mean the fact is with the stuff we've
done for the physics project
there is the beginning of if someone
from that team can we we can assist
and we can work on this joint but the
question is whether we can make
something which says you know black hole
you know event horizon value and things
like this right i don't know i mean
think about it for a second so the solid
mechanics so if if you have time space
that just has an e enormously large
um young's modulus
well yes it's just super super stiff
yes
so
you can do it with solid mechanics
okay so all of us
one of the things that is i think very
interesting is to try and use what we've
done for general relativity to apply it
to solid mechanics
right because i don't think that's
impossible that's going to work really
nicely i mean you know my long ago work
on cellular automaton fluids for fluid
mechanics
is actually a pretty reasonable thing to
do and something we should probably
support as a method for solving fluid
equations very different from nd solve
yeah right but but in the case of but
but this modeling framework you know the
question of are you using cellular
automata or using finite elements is
something below the level of this
modeling framework yeah in a perfect
world
right you would be able to set it up
with a modeling framework and then just
flip a switch to decide what underlying
pde solving technology you're using
and the same with and that's why
in the case of solid mechanics i think
it will be a super interesting thing to
try to look at
is could we actually use that underlying
technology from the physics project in
solid mechanics given the framework you
have here and i think it might just work
now i mean you know the framework you
have you know you're not dealing with
cracking you're not dealing with all
kinds of things
right crack propagation is not part of
your story here because that's an atomic
scale in the end the tip of the crack
has things going on like
in you know hypersonic flow or whatever
else that are outside of the domain
dealt with by the by continuing
mechanics if i'm not mistaken i'm sure i
mean it depends on on on what level you
want to look at this sure so you can
always the whole point is the crack
reveals
a crack as a crack in the continuum
mechanics basically yeah
because in continuum mechanics you know
a crack
a
shock wave of discontinuing mechanics
well indeed i mean attack a shock wave
an event horizon you know or singularity
in space time these are all
examples of continuum mechanics breaks
down
well that's why we have event
differential equations
well it's also why we are trying to make
models that actually describe space time
the level below the level of the
continuum it's also why
you know why i worked on fluid mechanics
at a level that is more like molecular
dynamics right right i mean these are
you know it's a the whole point is i
mean what is what would be very nice
about your modeling framework is to be
able to smoothly go from the continuum
description to something which could at
least be modeled by the non-continuum
just you know by the microdynamics type
description
and that seem i mean look there are
three levels of description in my view
okay
there is
the continuum mechanics pde description
you know study with finite elements
the pure molecular dynamics description
studied at an atomic level okay and
there's a third one which is what our
physics project has partly in it
which is these arbitrary dimensional
things which are sort of idealizations
they are above the level of
pure and in fact one thing we've been
doing recently is looking at hot sphere
gases
using the same technology as for the
physics project okay causal graphs and
all this kind of thing for hard sphere
gases
and so that's probably going to lead to
an intermediate description layer
between the pure point molecular
dynamics and the finite element stuff
and again seems to me that having the
you know the modeling framework that you
have be able to
you know access those things will be
super interesting
and and frankly
a
dramatic advantage from our
thing over anybody who's like well we're
just solving foreign elements the way
people have been doing that 50 years
yeah yeah
um so i think it's a thing to explore
and um
uh
um
right i need to go
i'm doing another live stream q a live
stream for people who are following this
um
and ethan is suggesting
weather forecasting for our
fluid mechanics no that is still some
distance away yeah
although we do have geo elevations yeah
i mean we don't have a cloud which is
cool but i'm not quite there yet but
keep it in mind you know one of the one
of the interesting questions is
with the stuff that we now have from the
physics project and its interaction with
the fluid mechanics stuff that i did
long ago i was i've been thinking it
might actually be possible to have a
completely different approach to solving
those kinds of equations that might
actually have
i mean plus the stuff we did as a matter
of fact with traffic modeling with this
network-based model of traffic modeling
which you guys probably don't didn't
didn't follow done for one of our uh
corporate customers um
uh
that's
they're probably some that they're
probably some very interesting things
that can be done and and this modeling
framework that you're making
seems to me it is the it is the ui for
all of that stuff so to speak
yeah and um
but i so i wouldn't obsess i really
wouldn't obsess about the the most
bizarre you know duck foot
yeah yeah
we had no intention to but we want to
push it a little further
so this looks nice okay thank you thank
you very much okay